[Music]
space movie can't resist long opening
sequence involving spaceship porn an
Arab force one space racist woman sweat
boots to smell to her tool belt why
would these people cryo sleep in a
janitor's outfit or any regular clothes
my favorite prostitute has the same
problem the ship is diving at a high
rate of speed and yet this asshole can
just walk around the ship without being
flown all over the place
I'm no space ologist but I think a
spaceship bettering the atmosphere would
be traveling at high enough speeds for
shattered glass from the window to kill
this girl instantly again how is this
spaceship crash landing at a leisurely
55 miles per hour
is that a totally fake sci-fi drug
combining anesthesia and morphine yeah
these motherfuckers are hardcore in the
future including on alien planets I've
never been on before
I guess lethal weapon too must have been
the in-flight movie also beam suddenly
has magic convenient space for Riddick
to fit his handcuffs through when it
clearly wasn't there earlier also huge
exhaust tube running alongside the beam
disappears when Riddick does his
contortion Act okay so this guy comes
running up and says you should see this
but then when they're looking at the
third Sun no one appears to have gone
anywhere at all I mean they give us the
establishing shot at a lookout guy with
a scope on the roof before this guy even
runs up to the group and he's there at
the end as well so this guy say I think
you should see this and then just
silently wait several minutes for the
third Sun to appear over the horizon
also how the far away from the crash
site but this guy have to have gone to
be able to see a Sun on the horizon that
couldn't be seen from the crash site
which means you went toward sunrise yeah
but if you Riddick wouldn't you know
that John's would think this or does
this just become like the i akane scene
in The Princess Bride I'm not so I can
clearly not use the wide in front of you
but you must have known I was not a
great fool you would have counted on it
so I can barely not use the wine in
front of me
no lights because that darkness so this
geological team that was here before had
no use whatsoever for a lamp
they just led in the blinding light
every time they need to read a book to
go to sleep at night if you're blindly
swinging a blade like this with the
intent to kill someone how do you stop
your momentum at the last second since
the guy was clearly not threatening and
looked nothing like Riddick but he gets
shot anyway what does he Bugs Bunny or
something oh now Riddick wants to get
away how was he doing when he decided to
kick back on the lawn chair on the open
a minute ago it was twenty nine minutes
before the film's main character speaks
an audible line of dialogue scene does
not contain a lapdance
ya experience bounty hunter drops his
guard when murderous convict gets his
change shot off it should be Riddick his
name is dick Riddick
movie set in the future tries to pass
off a Commodore 64 as a spaceship
monitor this kid has alien bats all over
and around his head and yet somehow
manages to get on the other side of the
door without any of them coming with him
I know it's pretty awesome when the
whole planet goes into for a long total
darkness but isn't that just a little
convenient that's the planet with three
suns and constant daylight is having its
once every twenty two years eclipse
while there are crash survivors on it
and darkness loving killer aliens and a
main character who sees really well in
the darkness this is this a personal
girl in black yeah well whatever I can
overlook to advance the plot now the
only way you people don't truly safe as
if he believes he's going free let's
talk about John's plan he needs to
transport Riddick alive because he's
worth twice as much alive than he is
dead so the idea is to make him think
he's gonna go free so that he doesn't do
anything to hurt the crew
but when fry suggests that Riddick could
help navigate something that would go a
long way to make Riddick believe that
very thing John's thinks Riddick might
kill the pilot then he says chains don't
hold this guy so what is the actual plan
John's can't just leave Riddick on the
planet or he gets no bounty and if he's
on the ship cons thinks ridiculous screw
everybody over and hijacked the ship of
course we never hear the entire plan
because
because fry constantly interrupts jeonse
to change don't work on this guy chains
don't hold this guy because you keep
putting him in easily escapable
situations or you're just shooting the
chains off of him yourself or the ship
crash lands I mean you can't account for
dumb luck and just being dumb here we
see the hatch closed and fry goes to
prep the ship then Riddick shows up out
of nowhere how again he doesn't have
anywhere to hide in this thing was
Riddick have the ability to blend into
stuff like the t1000 in Terminator 2
ever wonder why John shapes like that
ask can you just tell us i poking john's
just happens to be doing the very thing
that Riddick told Carolyn to ask John's
about when she goes to see him as the
Eclipse is about to happen it's a race
to the finish with these Saturn planets
moving quite rapidly but then they must
stop their orbit or something and just
hang there because the darkness lasts
forever after that at the read they were
rising into place the clip should last
in about ten minutes one hundred ninety
three thousand four hundred and sixty
five oh shit we need to get down thank
god there's a sudden trench right at
this moment also do nocturnal flying
creatures have an aversion to lower
elevation that I should be aware of and
if so how would she know this Shaza was
just torn in half I think her screaming
days are over
yeah well there's only a million of
these things flying around this is the
perfect time to get up and not worry
about anything also I guess these
creatures can't fly to areas just
outside of ships even if there is a ton
of meat there I guess we've established
that staying down is the defense these
creatures can penetrate an aversion to
lowness is common among flying monsters
I know the people here before you guys
were awfully bad at staying down how
does one give himself this option it's
not good motion
yeah but this its death Rock there
especially with the girl bleeding I'm
sorry did they just make this girl's
period a plot issue and for what just so
you could have a surprise that the in
essential character they think is a buoy
is actually a girl ridic pushes in
everyday somewhat round vulgar out of
the way of the cave entrance and then
when he pushes it back it magically
transforms into a taller triangular
exact fit for the opening to seal
everyone inside hero contemplates
leaving the innocent people behind even
though you know he's going to go back
for them cliche where the hell's it got
that it's funny Lieutenant Dan setback
because right then God showed
hi here
[Music]